make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back yet again to celebrate our
love of superheroes by finding ways to
kill them
that's how we at comics explains
celebrate our love of superheroes we get
rid of them and in this video we are
focusing on the cosmic ghost rider so
before we get into how to eliminate this
guy we'll get into his origin and powers
so we can see
what we're up against so the cosby ghost
rider was created by donnie cates and
jeff shaw and first appeared in thanos
number 13 and 2018. now as for his
origin he is actually a composite of a
few different characters and concepts
that already existed in the marvel
universe prior to his creation
originally the frank castle of his
universe and his origin was very similar
to the character origin
of the punisher frank castle in the main
marvel universe he's basically a guy
whose wife and son were
killed by members of the mob so it
becomes a vigilante dedicated to doling
out justice to criminals
unlike the main marvel universe version
this version of frank castle's earth
is basically invaded by thanos and all
the superheroes are killed in an attempt
to win the affection of mistress death
and so the punisher dies during the
earth's hero's final battle with thanos
when he struck by a piece of debris from
a building destroyed by the hulk and so
upon his death frank is sent to hell
where he strikes a deal with mephisto
in exchange for the opportunity to exact
his revenge on thanos for destroying his
planet
frank agrees to take on the spirit of
vengeance which transforms him
into the ghost rider now as a ghost
writer the problem with this is that as
the ghost rider frank castle can't leave
earth and so yes he wants his revenge
on thanos but he cannot actually get to
it but all this changes when frank is
visited by galactus who was injured by
thanos and frank convinces galactus to
make him his herald so the two of them
could hunt down thanos together and so
galactus agrees and abused frank with
the power cosmic a seemingly limitless
energy source that grants him a variety
of abilities such as teleportation
force field creation and energy blast as
well as matter manipulation
among other things and so upon receiving
the power cosmic frank becomes the
cosmic ghost rider and fights alongside
galactus for many years
until the devourer has his head blown
off by thanos and after killing galactus
thanos convinces frank to serve as his
right hand
as he rules the galaxy and so because he
possesses two of the most powerful
forces in the marvel universe cosmic
ghost rider is an extremely powerful
being and just to see how
powerful he is we'll go over what each
of these forces can give him
starting with the spirit of vengeance
and so like all the ghost riders frank
possesses the penance stare which forces
his victims to feel a physical pain
equal to the intensity of the amount of
pain they've inflicted on others
throughout their entire lives he's also
able to create and control hellfire an
extremely powerful flame that injures
not only the bodies but the souls of
those who are exposed to it now frank's
hellfire was so powerful that it took
out the entire horde of annihilus with
little difficulty and was also able to
melt thanos face off now from the power
cosmic
frank gets a variety of abilities some
of which we've mentioned but basically
it can manifest in almost any way he
chooses frank has been able to use the
power cosmic to create energy blast
strong enough to incapacitate thanos the
power cosmic greatly enhances frank's
physical attributes including his
strength and speed and in fact he's
moved at a rate of speed that's too fast
to be detected
by the tatari's extremely advanced
tracking computer and is able to move
from one side
of the galaxy to the other in the blink
of an eye and so while wielding both of
these forces
cosmic ghost rider was able to kill a
group of superheroes that included
wolverine
iron man hulk spider-man beta ray bill
cable storm
cyclops and vision among others now the
combination of these power sources also
served to make cosmic ghost rider
immortal
and virtually invulnerable he survived
repeated punches and eye blasts from
thanos as well as a blast from galactus
and after thanos kills galactus he
admits that he would be unable to kill
frank and so he recruits him instead and
so with all that said
how do we kill such a powerful entity
well before we answer that we need to
address
that he has been killed in comics before
when he was struck by mjolnir being
wielded by the silver surfer and so it's
possible for him to be killed as we've
seen it done but while silver surfer is
a really powerful character emulnier is
one of the strongest weapons in marvel
comics it really doesn't make sense
why this would be enough to take out the
cosmic ghost rider as
mjolnir has struck much weaker
characters than cosmic ghost rider
without killing them now this really
seems to just be what was dictated as
necessary by the plot but really cosmic
ghost rider has been injured by
characters like iron fist and kamala
khan which also makes no sense but we're
going to put that inconsistent writing
to the side and see what
logically would have to happen in order
to take out the cosmic ghost rider and
our success in doing this
is going to hinge on stripping frank of
the two things that are making him
powerful in the first place the power
cosmic and the spirit of vengeance now
as it relates to the power cosmic
there's only one way at least that i
know of of removing it from someone who
it's been given to
and that is for the source of the power
galactus to simply take it away there
might be a slight problem with this
since the galactus who imbued frank with
the power cosmic is dead but there are
several versions of galactus in the
marvel multiverse so it should be as
simple as figuring out a way
to transport a nigh omnipotent being
through the barriers that separate his
reality from frank's and convincing him
to go there and then take the power
cosmic
from french the only caveat to this is
i've never heard of an instance in
marvel comics where a galactus from one
universe
traveled to another universe and took
the power cosmic away from a person who
had it but it stands to reason that if
galactus is a universal constant
then every version of galactus across
the multiverse aside from the ultimate
universe would more or less be the same
meaning that they all have the power
cosmic they can all use it accordingly
right that of course is going off the
abraxas saga from the fantastic four
which the ultimate universe ultimately
changed that right so uh no pun intended
but i'm not really sure if that would be
the case but we're going to assume that
it is
right for the sake of this process we're
going to assume that it is now as for
the spirit of vengeance separating the
spirit from its current host
is possible and doing so results in the
killing of the host we see a spirit
separated from its host in an alternate
universe during the events of what if
number 28 which centers around the
question of what would happen if the
spirit was separated from its host
johnny blaze and in this what if issue a
mage known as
azizia azazia i don't know anyway a guy
named hornsby separates the spirit of
vengeance from johnny blaze and takes
the spirit for himself
later blaze would use an artifact called
the scimitar of
ramon beth to kill this guy to kill
hornsby but it also kills blaze and
spirit itself and so if we can hop
across universal barriers once again to
the reality where this scimitar exists
we could use it to take out frank after
he's stripped of the power cosmic if we
cannot get our hands on the scimitar
then we're left with the option of
separating the spirit of vengeance
from frank through a sufficiently
powerful act of magic which would kill
frank and thereby
accomplish our goal the only way i could
really consider us being able to do that
at least having sufficient levels of
power to do that we would probably have
to visit the center's market and then
basically bargain away
100 of our soul for 100 of absolute
power that's the only way that i could
consider us doing that either that or
somehow getting mephisto to do it which
i doubt would actually happen by the way
if you're wondering why johnny blaze
didn't die when he was separated from
the spirit in that what if
it's basically because that issue came
out in the early 80s several years
before we see blaze die at the hands of
blade
in the early 1990s during the siege of
darkness storyline where blade has his
powers bolstered by an entity known as a
demogorge that possessed blade and
allowed him to absorb ghostwriter's
power
we need to cover that story so our plan
to kill ghost rider is basically to
convince galactus to strip him of the
power cosmic and then enlist a sorcerer
of sufficient magical prowess to
separate frank from the spirit of
vengeance thereby ending his life but
let me know what you guys think
leave a comment down below let me know
what you guys think about this but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an
end if you are new here to comics
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
you